In 2015,
the podcast entitled “Serial”
[and] docuseries like “Making a Murderer”
and “The Staircase”
were the hottest topics in pop culture.
I was late to the "Serial" obsession,
but when I dipped my toe in
a few months after its initial release,
I quickly dove headfirst
into the exploding true crime world.
I was obsessed.
I have written a dissertation,
articles, a book,
and after countless hours
consuming true crime,
I'm still obsessed.
As part of my research and my obsession,
I attempted to quantify and categorize
true crime podcasts,
just one tiny piece
of the exploding true crime world.
As of April 2022,
I had identified nearly 5,000,
and that number keeps growing.
Our obsession with true crime isn't new.
While scholars generally credit
Truman Capote's 1966 "In Cold Blood"
as the birth of true crime media,
it's easy to find examples
that predate Capote by decades.
Consider the “Transatlantic Terror”
inspired by Jack the Ripper
and H.H. Holmes in the 1880s and '90s,
or how Elizabeth Short's 1947 murder
inspired lurid media frenzy
and the Black Dahlia lore.
It could even be argued
that public executions in the Middle Ages,
the witch trials, even the Inquisition,
were early examples
of true crime entertainment.
Then, as now, spectators would watch,
fascinated and horrified
at the intersections of good and evil,
justice and injustice
played out before them in grim spectacles.
It seems there is something innate in us
that is drawn to crimes
or perceived crimes
and the associated horrors.
While I have always enjoyed both
true crime and crime fiction,
my real obsession took off
with the zeitgeist.
I’m a multitasker,
so podcasts felt made for me.
As I dove deeper down
the "Serial" rabbit hole,
I began to expand my attention
to other true crime narratives,
and I noticed a new pattern emerging.
While lots of creators
were focused on entertainment,
others were focused
on criminal justice reform,
on wrongful convictions,
on bringing attention to long-cold,
unsolved cases.
I found this elating.
So much so that I changed
my whole research stream
to devote my time to better understanding
this particular type
of true crime entertainment.
But when I would have conversations
with other people about my obsession,
especially people
outside of true crime fandom,
the same questions would emerge.
Is this OK?
Doesn't this feel icky?
Are they laughing about murders?
I would shrug off those criticisms
or instead point them towards
what I thought of as the good stuff:
to the creators and storytellers
who were solving cases, finding new leads,
drawing attention to long-cold
cases and injustices.
That's the good stuff.
But when I would let myself look
at the ugly side of true crime,
it was really, really ugly.
In 2018, I started interviewing
storytellers, journalists, advocates
who were involved
in true crime storytelling.
I wanted to know how they personally
navigated this dichotomy.
I asked them to define true crime
and to talk about its reputation.
Obviously, they would gush
about the good stuff,
but other words kept coming up.
Exploitative,
salacious,
prurient,
murder porn.
And just like the famous quote
about traditional pornography,
all of my interviewees told me
that while they couldn't define
bad true crime,
they all knew it when they saw it.
So today I am here to offer
those of you who, like me,
might be a little obsessed,
four questions to ask yourself
about the real-world implications
of your true crime consumption.
I've based these questions
from talking to people
involved in the storytelling,
but also listening to people
who have been affected
by their tragic connections
to these stories.
It is my hope that by becoming
more mindful consumers
of true crime media,
we can direct our attention,
our resources, our dollars
towards the people doing the good work.
So question number one, ask yourself:
"Why am I interested in this?"
There's no right answer to this question.
Multiple studies have shown
that true crime fans, particularly women,
are drawn to the sense of community.
So many of us have been
ourselves survivors
or know other survivors
and victims of assault, harassment,
even murder.
Hearing the stories
of others can be healing.
We can feel empowered
to fight back and feel less alone.
On the other hand,
sometimes interest in a true crime story
is driven by horror
or titillation or morbid curiosity.
While those feelings are natural
and they're valid,
if that's the only reason
that you're interested in a story,
it might be time to find something new.
Question number two:
"How does this make me feel?"
True crime fans know that true crime
is rarely a feel-good story.
And yet, we still seek out that content.
For some people,
the excitement and the motivation
are in learning about a new topic.
For others,
there’s what media psychologists
call a “eudaimonic motivation.”
That is,
we are interested for reasons
beyond pleasure or hedonic motivations.
For example, in my own listening,
I've known myself
to finish a victim's story
not because it was well told
or even necessarily interesting to me,
but because I felt like I owed attention
to this person's tragedy,
especially in the case of victims
who are less likely to receive
coverage in mainstream press
like Black men or Indigenous girls.
On the other hand,
sometimes the interest is driven
because it's exciting,
because the story is thrilling,
it's well-produced,
it's filled with fascinating characters.
While those hedonic motivations
are not inherently problematic,
again, if that's the only reason
you're interested in a story,
it might be time to reevaluate
that consumption.
Question number three,
and this is a big one:
"How might the people
involved in this story feel?"
This can be a complicated question.
Take, for example,
the ubiquitous "Serial" case.
Advocates for Adnan Syed,
the man that many believe is a victim
of wrongful conviction,
have written books,
produced documentaries
and recorded hours and hours
of podcast about the case.
They frame their arguments
in that they are searching justice
not only for Adnan,
but also for Hae Min Lee,
the young girl whose death
is at the center of the story.
And yet, while these are noble causes,
Hae's family is famously absent
from the narratives.
And they've issued statements saying
that there are deep wounds
that this remediation of her story opens.
Does that make telling Hae's story
inherently unethical?
Not necessarily.
True crime storytelling,
much like traditional journalism,
delves into painful subjects.
Sometimes that means
private citizens' public lives --
or private citizens' lives
become public information.
Sometimes that means wounds are reopened.
Criminologist Elizabeth Yardley
has written extensively
about the ethics of crime storytelling.
She urges true crime fans to remember,
in the words of a Reddit post
made by Hae Min Lee's brother,
"To us, it's real life."
Lee has criticized "Serial" producers
for leaving his family out
of these narratives.
In that Reddit post, he goes on to say,
"To you, it's another murder mystery,
a crime drama, an episode of CSI.
You weren't there to see
your mom crying every night.
Shame on you.
I hope that what happens to us
never happens to you
and you have to have your story
blasted to five million listeners."
When discovering new
true crime narratives, ask yourself,
are the people in this story being hurt?
And if so, is there a justifiable
reason to inflict that harm?
Can some good come
from retelling the story?
Or is it just for entertainment?
If the answer is the latter, again,
may be time to find something new.
And finally,
my last question to ask yourself
to make you more aware
of the real-world impacts
of your true crime consumption is this:
"Am I motivated to act?"
In my experience, my favorites,
the things I consider
the really good stuff,
things like “In The Dark”
and “Truth and Justice” and the inimitable
“Undisclosed” podcast,
they leave listeners with a mission.
To donate, to contact
a member of Congress,
to work within our own
communities for healing,
for ourselves and for others.
On the other hand,
most of the true crime
that I find really questionable
leaves me feeling helpless or afraid.
It focuses too much
on the horrors or the injustices
and not enough on healing or solutions.
There's a world of difference
between a creator who plays a 911 call
to horrify his audience
with anguished screams,
and the one who plays a call in hopes
that someone will hear a clue,
maybe a passing truck or rushing water
that helps find where a missing
victim disappeared.
The ethical creators will draw
these lines around their motivations.
They will remind their listeners
that looking through court
transcripts could be helpful
but harassing victims, family members
or suspects online is not.
While these four questions:
how does this make me feel;
why am I interested in this;
how might the people involved feel;
and does this motivate me to act;
cannot alone create a world
of less exploitative,
more ethical true crime,
our individual consumption has impacts.
It is my hope
that by directing our attention
to the people doing the good stuff,
that we can turn our time
and our dollars and our resources,
we can use that ourselves
as murderinos, as fans,
and amplify the potential for good
in our true crime obsession.
(Applause)